B. Giussani : Commissaire, merci d'être venu à TED.
A. Guterres: Merci à vous.
BG : Commençons par un chiffre.
En 2015, presque un million de réfugiés et de migrants sont arrivés en Europe
en provenance de nombreux pays,
bien évidemment, de Syrie et d’Irak, mais aussi d'Afghanistan,
du Bangladesh, d'Érythrée et d'ailleurs.
Et il y a eu deux types de réactions :
des fêtes de bienvenue et des barrières frontalières.
Mais je veux examiner ça
sous l'angle du court terme et du long terme.
La première question est très simple : pourquoi le mouvement de réfugiés
a-t-il connu une hausse si soudaine ces six derniers mois ?
AG : Eh bien, je pense qu'à l'origine de cette augmentation massive,
il y a le groupe de réfugiés syriens.
Il y a eu en Europe une intensification du mouvement de réfugiés
venus d'Afrique et d'Asie,
qui augmentait lentement,
mais tout d'un coup il y a eu une augmentation énorme
dans les premiers mois de l'année.
Pourquoi ? Pour trois raisons,
deux à long terme et un déclencheur.
Les raisons à long terme, concernant les Syriens,
sont qu'il y a de moins en moins d'espoir pour ces personnes.
Ils regardent leur propre pays,
et ne voient pas beaucoup d'espoir de rentrer chez eux,
parce qu'il n'y a pas de solution politique
et donc pas de lumière au bout du tunnel.
La seconde, les conditions de vie
des Syriens dans les pays frontaliers se sont détériorées.
On vient de faire des recherches avec la Banque mondiale
et 87 % des Syriens en Jordanie
et 93 % des Syriens au Liban
vivent en dessous des seuils de pauvreté nationaux.
Seulement la moitié des enfants vont à l'école,
ce qui signifie que les gens vivent très mal.
Non seulement ils sont réfugiés, hors de chez eux,
non seulement ils ont énormément souffert,
mais ils vivent dans des conditions vraiment très difficiles.
Le déclencheur, c'est que tout à coup,
l'aide internationale a diminué.
Le Programme alimentaire mondial
a été forcé, par manque de ressources
de diminuer de 30 % l'aide alimentaire aux réfugiés syriens.
Ils ne sont pas autorisés à travailler,
donc ils dépendent totalement de l'aide internationale
et ils se disent : « le monde nous abandonne ».
Et selon moi, c'est l'élément déclencheur.
Tout à coup, il y a eu une ruée,
les gens ont commencé à se déplacer en masse,
et pour être absolument honnête,
si j'avais été dans la même situation
et j'avais eu assez de courage pour le faire,
je pense que j'aurais fait la même chose.
BG : Mais ce qui a surpris beaucoup de gens,
ce n'est pas seulement le caractère soudain,
car ça ne devait pas être soudain.
La guerre en Syrie durait depuis cinq ans.
Des millions de réfugiés sont dans des camps
et des villages autour de la Syrie.
Vous avez vous-même alerté sur cette situation,
et les conséquences d'un renversement de la Libye, par exemple,
et pourtant l'Europe a semblée totalement prise au dépourvu.
AG : En effet, car elle était divisée,
et lorsque vous êtes divisés,
vous ne voulez pas admettre la réalité,
vous préférez reporter les décisions à plus tard,
car vous n'êtes pas en mesure de les prendre,
et la preuve est que même quand le pic est arrivé,
l'Europe est resté divisée,
et était incapable de mettre en place un mécanisme pour contrôler la situation.
Vous parlez d'environ 1 million de personnes,
cela paraît énorme,
mais la population de l'Union Européenne est de 550 millions de personnes
ce qui signifie que nous parlons d'une personne pour 2000 Européens.
Maintenant, au Liban, nous avons un réfugié pour trois Libanais.
Et le Liban ? Il lutte bien sûr, mais il s'en sort.
Donc, la question est : est-ce qu'on aurait pu contrôler ça,
si... sans parler du plus important,
il aurait fallu s'occuper des causes ;
mais si on oublie ces causes pour l'instant,
et qu'on considère le phénomène lui-même,
si l'Europe était capable s'unir avec solidarité
pour créer une capacité de réception adéquate à chaque point d'entrée ?
Mais pour ça, les pays aux points d'entrée doivent recevoir une aide importante
et il faut filtrer les entrants avec des contrôles de sécurité
et tous les autres mécanismes
en les répartissant dans tous les pays européens
en fonction des possibilités de chaque pays.
Si vous regardez le programme de réinstallation
approuvé par la Commission — toujours trop tard
ou par le Conseil, toujours trop peu et trop tard.
BG : C'est déja un échec.
AG : Mon pays est censé en recevoir 4000.
4000 au Portugal, c'est rien.
Donc c'est parfaitement faisable si c'est bien géré,
mais dans les circonstances actuelles, la pression est sur le point d'entrée,
et à mesure que les populations traversent les Balkans de cette manière chaotique,
alors ils vont en Allemagne, en Suède, principalement, et en Autriche
ce sont les trois pays au final, qui reçoivent des réfugiés.
Le reste de l'Europe regarde, sans faire grand chose.
BG : Permettez-moi de vous poser trois questions
en me faisant un peu l'avocat du diable.
Je vais les poser de façon directe.
Mais je pense que ces questions sont très présentes
dans l'esprit de beaucoup d'Européens aujourd'hui.
La première est bien sûr à propos du nombre.
Vous dites que 550 millions contre 1 million, ce n'est pas grand chose
mais concrètement combien de personnes l'Europe peut-elle accueillir ?
AG : Eh bien, cette question n'a pas de réponse,
parce que les réfugiés ont le droit d'être protégés.
La loi internationale, ça existe,
donc il n'est pas possible de dire, « J'en prends 10 000 et c'est tout. »
Laissez-moi vous rappeler ceci :
en Turquie, au début de la crise, je me souviens qu'un ministre a dit,
« La Turquie sera capable d'accueillir jusqu'à 100 000 personnes. »
La Turquie a maintenant 2,3 millions,
à peu près, si on compte tous les réfugiés.
Donc je ne pense pas que ça soit juste de dire combien on peut en accueillir.
Ce qui est pertinent de dire c'est : comment peut-on s'organiser
pour assumer nos responsabilités internationales ?
Et l'Europe n'a pas été capable de le faire,
surtout parce qu'elle est divisée, parce qu'il n'y a pas de solidarité
dans le projet européen.
Et ce n'est pas que pour les réfugiés, c'est vrai dans d'autres domaines.
Soyons francs, c'est là que nous avons besoin de plus d'Europe
au lieu de moins d'Europe.
Mais puisque le public croit de moins en moins
en les institutions européennes,
il devient plus difficile de convaincre l'opinion publique
que nous avons besoin de plus d'Europe pour résoudre ces problèmes.
BG : Il semble que les chiffres deviennent politiques,
particulièrement au sein de chaque pays.
On l'a revu ce weekend en France
mais on l'a vu encore et encore dans de nombreux pays
en Pologne au Danemark, en Suisse et ailleurs,
où le climat change radicalement à cause des chiffres,
bien qu'ils ne soient pas significatifs en nombre absolu.
Le Premier Ministre de —
AG : Si je puis me permettre à ce propos.
Je veux dire, qu'est-ce qu'un Européen voit chez lui
dans un village où il n'y a aucun migrant ?
Ce qu'un Européen voit, à la télévision,
chaque jour, depuis quelques mois, à la une des journaux télévisés
une foule qui arrive, incontrôlée,
passant de frontière en frontière,
et des images à la télévision avec des centaines,
des milliers de personnes qui bougent.
Et le message est que personne ne s'en occupe.
C'est en train de se passer sans aucun contrôle.
Et ils se disent : « Ils vont arriver dans mon village. »
Il y avait cette idée complètement fausse que l'Europe était envahie
que notre manière de vivre allait changer, que tout allait —
Le problème c'est que, si cela avait été géré convenablement,
si les gens avaient été reçus et accueillis correctement,
pris en charge, filtrés au point d'entrée,
et transportés par avion dans les différents pays européens,
cela n'aurait pas fait peur aux gens.
Mais, malheureusement, beaucoup de gens ont peur,
parce que l'Europe n'a pas fait son travail correctement.
BG : Mais il y a des villages en Allemagne
de 300 habitants avec 1000 réfugiés.
Dans ce cas, quelle est votre position ?
Comment imaginez-vous la réaction de ces populations ?
AG : S'il y avait eu une gestion appropriée de la situation
et une répartition convenable des migrants en Europe,
vous auriez partout le pourcentage dont j'ai parlé :
1 pour 2000 habitants.
C'est parce que la situation n'a pas été bien gérée
qu'au final nous arrivons à ces situations
qui sont tout à fait invivables, et bien sûr si vous avez un village —
au Liban, il y a beaucoup de villages
où il y a plus de Syriens que de Libanais, le Liban vit avec cela.
Je ne demande pas à ce que la même chose arrive en Europe,
que tous les villages européens aient plus de réfugiés que d'habitants.
Ce que je demande c'est que l'Europe fasse correctement son travail,
et qu'elle soit capable de s'organiser pour accueillir les gens
comme d'autres pays dans le monde ont dû le faire par le passé.
BG : Donc la situation globale pas juste l'Europe —
(Applaudissements)
BG: Oui !
BG : Si on regarde la situation globale, pas seulement l'Europe,
je sais que l'on peur faire une longue liste de pays
qui ne sont pas à la hauteur,
mais le contraire m’intéresse plus —
y-a-t-il quelqu'un qui fait les choses bien ?
AG : Et bien, 86 % des réfugiés dans le monde
sont dans les pays en développement.
Et si on regarde des pays comme l'Ethiopie —
l'Ethiopie a reçu plus de 600 000 réfugiés.
Toutes les frontières de l'Ethiopie sont ouvertes
et ils ont comme politique,
qu'ils appellent "échange ", le fait que chaque réfugié doit être accueilli.
Et ils ont des Soudanais du sud,
des Soudanais, des Somaliens.
Ils ont tout leurs voisins.
Ils ont des Érythréens.
Et, en général,
les pays africains sont extrêmement accueillants envers les réfugiés,
et je dirais qu'au Moyen-Orient
et en Asie, la tendance est aux frontières ouvertes.
Aujourd'hui on voit des problèmes avec la situation syrienne,
et elle a évolué en une crise sécuritaire majeure,
mais la vérité est que pendant longtemps,
toutes les frontières au Moyen-Orient étaient ouvertes.
La vérité pour les Afghans
c'est que les frontières du Pakistan et de l'Iran étaient ouvertes :
6 millions d'Afghans sont partis.
Donc je dirais que même aujourd'hui, la tendance dans les pays dévéloppés
est à l'ouverture des frontières.
Cette question des frontières dans les pays développés,
est de plus en plus compliquée,
surtout quand il y a, dans l'opinion publique,
des débats mêlés : la protection des réfugiés d'un côté
et des questions de sécurité — à mon avis mal interprétées — de l'autre côté.
BG : Nous reviendrons à cela également
mais vous avez mentionné la baisse des financements et des bons
de le part du World Food Programme.
Cela reflète le sous-financement des organisations
qui travaillent sur ces problématiques.
Aujourd'hui le monde semble se réveiller et prendre conscience de la situation
recevez-vous plus de financement, de soutien
ou la situation est toujours la même ?
AG : Nous obtenons plus de soutien
je dirais que nous sommes proches du niveau de l'an dernier.
Nous étions beaucoup plus mal cet été.
Mais c'est clairement insuffisant pour répondre aux besoins des populations
et répondre aux besoins des pays
qui s'occupent ces populations.
Et il existe des critères, des objectifs
et des priorités requis par les organisations de développement.
Par exemple le Liban et la Jordanie sont des pays à revenu intermédiaire
parce qu'ils sont des pays à revenu intermédiaire
ils ne peuvent recevoir des prêts ou des subventions de la Banque Mondiale.
Aujourd'hui ça n'a aucun sens
car ils œuvrent pour un bien public mondial.
Ils ont des millions de réfugiés là-bas,
et honnêtement, ils sont les piliers de la stabilité dans la région
avec toutes les difficultés qu'ils connaissent,
et la première ligne de défense de notre sécurité collective.
Donc cela n'a aucun sens
que ces pays ne soient pas la priorité
des politiques de coopération de développement
et ils ne le sont pas.
Et non seulement les réfugiés vivent dans des conditions effroyables
à l'intérieur de ces pays,
mais les communautés locales souffrent également,
parce que les salaires ont chuté,
parce que le chômage a augmenté,
parce que les prix et les loyers ont grimpé.
Et, bien sûr, si vous regardez la situation aujourd'hui,
les indicateurs dans ces pays,
il est clair que leur population, surtout les franges les plus pauvres,
vivent de plus en plus mal, du fait de la crise qu'ils traversent.
BG : Qui devrait fournir ce soutien
les pays, les organisations internationales,
l'Union Européenne ? Qui ?
AG : Nous devons joindre tous nos efforts.
Il est évident que la coopération bilatérale et multilatérale.
sont nécessaires.
Il est évident que les institutions financières mondiales
devrait avoir plus de flexibilité dans le but d'investir plus massivement
pour le soutien de ces pays.
Nous devons combiner tous ces instruments et comprendre qu'aujourd'hui,
lors de situations prolongées, et à un certain moment,
cela n'a aucun sens de faire la distinction
entre aide humanitaire et aide au développement
ou processus de développement.
Parce qu'il s'agit d'enfants à l'école,
il s'agit de santé,
il s'agit de structures bondées.
Il s'agit de choses qui nécessite une vision à long terme,
une vision pour le développement,
et non seulement une aide humanitaire d'urgence.
BG : Je souhaiterais votre avis sur quelque chose
qui était dans les journaux ce matin.
C'est une déclaration faite par le favori à la nomination républicaine
pour l'élection présidentielle aux État-Unis Donald Trump.
Hier, il a dit cela.
(Rires)
Non, écoutez ça. C'est intéressant.
Je cite: « J'en appelle à une fermeture totale et complète
des entrées de Musulmans aux États-Unis,
jusqu'à ce que les institutions de ce pays sachent ce qu'il se passe. »
Comment vous réagissez à cela?
AG : Et bien, ce n'est pas que Donald Trump.
Nous avons vu plusieurs responsables politiques
dire à travers le monde, par exemple
que les réfugiés musulmans ne devraient pas être accueillis.
Et la raison pour laquelle ils disent cela
c'est parce qu'ils pensent qu'en disant ou faisant ça,
ils protègent la sécurité de leur pays.
J'ai été au gouvernement.
Je suis bien au courant de la nécessité des gouvernements
de protéger la sécurité de leur pays
et de leur peuple.
Mais si vous dites, comme ça,
aux États-Unis ou dans n'importe quel pays d'Europe,
« Nous allons fermer nos frontières aux réfugiés musulmans. »,
ce que vous dites est la meilleure aide possible
à la propagande des organisations terroristes.
Parce que ce que vous dites —
(Applaudissements)
Parce que ce que vous dites sera entendu par les musulmans dans votre propre pays,
et cela ouvrira la voie au recrutement
et aux mécanismes qui font que, grâce aux technologies,
Daesh et al-Nusra, al-Qaeda, et tous les autres groupes
pénètrent aujourd'hui nos sociétés, et cela revient à leur dire :
« Vous avez raison, nous sommes contre vous. »
Et cela crée évidemment, dans des sociétés multiethniques,
multireligieuses, multiculturelles,
une situation dans la laquelle
il est bien plus facile pour la propagande et les organisations terroristes
d'être efficaces dans le recrutement de terroristes
au sein des pays où ce type de déclaration est fait.
BG : Est-ce que les récentes attaques de Paris et ses réactions
rendent votre travail plus difficile ?
AG : Sans aucun doute.
BG : Dans quel sens ?
AG : Du fait que, pour beaucoup de gens, la première réaction
face à ce genre d'attaques est de fermer toutes les frontières —
sans voir que le problème du terrorisme en Europe est principalement intérieur.
Nous avons des milliers et des milliers de soldats européens en Syrie et en Iraq,
donc ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on résout seulement
en interdisant aux Syriens de venir,
Et je suis convaincu que le passeport que l'on a retrouvé,
a été déposé par la personne qui —
BG :— s'est faite explosée, oui.
AG : Je crois c'était voulu,
car une partie de la stratégie de Daesh est contre les réfugiés,
parce qu'ils voient les réfugiés comme des gens
qui devraient être avec le califat et se réfugient auprès des croisés.
Et je pense que la stratégie de Daesh consiste à forcer l'Europe
à faire fermer les frontières aux réfugiés musulmans
et créer de l'hostilité envers les musulmans au sein de l'Europe,
précisément pour faciliter le travail de Daesh.
Et ma conviction profonde est que le mouvement de réfugiés
n'a pas déclenché le terrorisme.
Je pense comme je l'ai dit, le terrorisme en Europe
est essentiellement un terrorisme intérieur
qui vient de la situation globale à laquelle nous faisons face.
Et ce dont nous avons besoin c'est de leur prouver le contraire,
en accueillant et en intégrant efficacement,
ceux qui viennent de cette région du monde.
Et je crois également que dans une large mesure,
nous payons aujourd'hui en Europe
le prix de l'échec des modèles d'intégration
qui ont échoué dans les années 1960, 1970 et 1980,
suite aux vagues de migration massives de cette époque
et qui ont généré, chez beaucoup de gens,
par exemple chez les secondes générations,
le sentiment d'être marginalisé,
d'être au chômage,
d'avoir une éducation inappropriée,
de vivre dans des quartiers dépourvus
d'infrastructures publiques.
Et cette sorte de malaise, parfois même de colère,
qui existe chez les secondes générations
est largement dû à l'échec des politiques d'intégration,
à l'échec d'un investissement qui aurait dû être plus considérable
dans la création de conditions adéquates au vivre ensemble et respect mutuel.
Pour moi c'est clair.
(Applaudissements)
Pour moi c'est clair que toutes les sociétés
seront multiethniques, muticulturelles, multireligieuses dans le futur.
Eviter cela est, je pense, impossible.
Et pour moi c'est une bonne chose que cela devienne comme ça,
mais je reconnais que, pour que cela fonctionne,
il faut un investissement énorme
pour la cohésion sociale de votre société.
Et l'Europe, a en grande partie échoué dans cet investissement
au cours des dernières décennies.
BG : Une question, vous vous retirez de votre poste à la fin de l'année,
après 10 ans.
Si vous revenez sur 2005, lorsque vous êtes
entré en fonction pour la première fois, qu'est-ce que vous voyez ?
AG : Et bien, écoutez.
En 2005, nous aidions un million de personnes à rentrer chez eux
dans la sécurité et la dignité, parce que les conflits avaient cessés.
L'année dernière nous avons aidé 124 000 personnes.
En 2005 nous avions environ 38 millions de personnes
déplacées à cause de conflits dans le monde.
Aujourd'hui nous en avons plus de 60 millions.
A cette époque, certains conflit venaient de se résoudre.
Aujourd'hui,on voit une multiplication des conflits
et les vieux conflits ne meurent jamais :
Afghanistan, Somalie, République Démocratique du Congo.
Il est clair que le monde est aujourd'hui bien plus dangereux qu'il ne l'était.
Il est clair que la capacité de la communauté internationale
pour empêcher les conflits et les résoudre en temps et en heure,
est, malheureusement, bien plus faible qu'elle ne l'était il y a 10 ans.
Il n'y a aucune relation claire dans le monde,
aucun mécanisme de gouvernance mondiale qui fonctionne,
ce qui signifie que nous vivons dans une situation
où l'impunité et l'imprévisibilié tendent à prévaloir,
et ça veut dire que de plus en plus de gens souffrent,
à savoir ceux qui sont déplacés par les conflits.
BG : C'est une tradition dans la vie politique américaine
lorsqu'un Président quitte le bureau ovale pour la dernière fois,
il laisse une note manuscrite sur le bureau à son successeur
qui arrive quelques heures après.
Si vous deviez écrire une note à votre successeur
Filippo Grandi, qu'est ce que vous écririez ?
AG : Je pense que je n'écrirais rien.
Vous savez, une des choses terribles quand une personne quitte son travail
c'est d'essayer de devenir un copilote,
en disant au nouveau quoi faire
donc je ne ferai pas ça.
Si je devais lui dire quelque chose,
je dirais : " Soyez vous-même et faites de votre mieux. "
BG : Commissaire merci pour le travail que vous faites.
Merci d'être venu à TED.
(Applaudissements)